I came up with I got okay
morning YouTube Monday morning walking
here in the High Line which is gorgeous
by the way if you come to New York City
you gotta check it out or do you rock
yeah nothing we take advantage of it
enough you guys made no vain or acts
created a holding company got the agency
vaynermedia on this side got the gallery
on this side pure Wow sitting under
there so we have a lot to do and so I'm
[ __ ] around doing my normal exciting
entrepreneurship let's do club Arlette
about it [ __ ] that yeah a podcast
infrastructure around the gallery and
get the right pieces in place first
that's smart you start to pull up I'm
getting fired up calling all creators
right now need to create a content army
who are designers who love to make mean
content and Instagram video editors who
can take this video rant for example
that we've just been doing and create 19
pieces of content and love that idea
no dear ugh you know what I like about
you and I we like the dirty work I'm a
creator at vaynermedia com will create a
Google Form I'm a creator at vaynermedia
com full-time job need to come in and
rock and roll 40 to 100 hours a week
depending on how we structure it let's
do this so there's that that was fun
little commercial break Jets lost that's
huge I guess I forgot I was in college
the 97 Jets season when I knew they were
gonna be the worst team in football I'm
excited about today morning snapchat you
rock and I hustling what's your Monday
focus what Jersey Rock
nice you answered it by the way but
we're building at Hudson yard well not
wait what they're building at Hudson
Yards this sculpture right outside our
office is [ __ ] going to the awesome
she's coming from Trenton are you in
Trenton you coming up I came up with I
got something we we've we've got
something Andy to his credit because the
teamwork but what we did is we created
an event called giving away free food
party at Wine Library like this Saturday
for example we will give you a coupon
you then can apply that $10 towards free
food you know if the buy anything you
got to do anything you just sleep you
sleep with a high-end cheese and a piece
of sausage and go to Short Hills Mall
yeah I think it's me [ __ ] awesome I'm
excited about it or ad-rock you have to
go an important senior executive meeting
with a client that can grow so this is
off limits but having a good day so far
and wine talking now vaynermedia
domination talk here's what I meet about
micro fast literally on a daily basis
I am scrutinizing 12 to 15 hours a day
and trying to fill in as much stuff and
as smartest stuff into that bucket right
so that's micro speed big idea like
let's do a food truck event tweet it out
put on my Instagram inbox comes in email
the team at Wine Library hey and now I
did it before it did it hey Brandon so
this whole food truck things if you're
in Berkeley Heights New Jersey you need
to come sorry bran I'm just filming my
vlog YouTube is now very near and dear
to me I now speak to YouTube when I do
daily V do you understand Brandon I
understand alright so anyway I'm me and
Tyler gonna keep sending you as they
come in you know always in the summer
when I spend a week with my dad
in New Jersey as a family it always gets
my juices going and so you always see in
August early September push for me on
the family business and so doing a bunch
of cool stuff please come and visit the
store check it out we're doing a lot of
rad stuff
so nice so you talk about being
self-aware huh percent I genuinely
believe the biggest mistake that most
artists make is they don't realize if
they are business as well right and the
biggest part and the biggest mistake
that business people make is they don't
realize if there are turn I mean the
amount of business quantum math sales
conversion making should happen guys and
gals that also think that their pottery
is beautiful or they can sing it
thank you man it's super nice might
actually send it to us Curtis I got
something for you let's step can't wait
to share it nice having the balance of
put doing something nice for somebody on
the way up Karma giving back to the game
and then [ __ ] 30 minutes with [ __ ]
LeBron Ray rod or [ __ ] you know kodak
black yeah right like what I'm trying to
do right all [ __ ] my time which is
where I make my money people confused
but that I'm taking my own advice that
they watch that's why I work 18 hours a
day so I can do this wall run up to a
million dollar business every [ __ ]
day I'm giving away things for free the
hardest thing my time yeah which comes
out of my leisure my relaxing my family
time yeah so well why would I be the
biggest artist because I would [ __ ]
make paintings for everybody who I
strategically thought mattered and I'm
really good at knowing where the world
goes sir
time okay there's some registration I
get a quick fish of course you know
taking time off I'd be lying if I didn't
feel fresher because August not in the
same patterns breakup pattern so we have
things to do we have the podcast we have
me driving a [ __ ] 25 to 50 percent
top-line growth which we should 100% do
we have a lot to do
yeah a podcast infrastructure around the
gallery and get the right pieces in
place for that's smart that's smart
concise just had a super high-level
meeting with with our business partners
from related Steven Ross on a dolphin's
his whole crew his
his infrastructure to work with me Ryan
and Mary Kate from pure Wow in the
gallery the holding company under
Boehner X that supports that just media
company of the future that's what we're
doing YouTube for what for he's gonna
apply to a bunch of ECE jobs okay get me
a three-minute call with him next week
while I'm traveling so I can talk him
out of BC jobs all you [ __ ] trying to
get these VC jobs it's a huge mistake
when you're not ready for it everybody
thinks we cease jobs are like [ __ ] you
know like playing backyard basketball
these are financial these institutions
have massive financial rigor and
experience like and more importantly
like the VC train is like not you know
it's a little tired like and I don't
know everybody just wants to be a VC
before they ever proved anything like
unless you've gone out and built a big
business and had an exit made a ton of
money or you you're the 1% of the 1% in
the financial [ __ ] apex of schools or
organizations you're not gonna be C job
that matters how are you gonna try to
seem in the cement really good I think
let's do it
I've been like fascinated with this
concept of will get multiple people like
tasting wine blind I'm just gonna ask
some questions to let the kind of
conversation go and feel free to talk
about anything that's important to you
well good you ready set
hey guys scary Vaynerchuk obviously I've
been super excited about this brown
blind brown paper bags concept 8:41
going to another meeting now talk about
some projects probably gonna wrap up
there like 11 I will send you a video to
prove it dear ex
good Dec good there haven't eaten like
for days so like stepping like three
glasses of wine I'm like not even like
drinking and I'm like a weirdly tipsy
welcome to the first episode of what
wine goes with real quick so many comics
here please leave more questions in the
YouTube comments listening point from
alien pit Pritz this guy consistently
two meanings manages a massive business
manager social and still has time to
like fans comments respect I appreciate
that comment because I'm trying to do
macro things and run you know 200
million dollar business and build one of
the biggest you know kind of brands
around entrepreneurship but I think one
of the ways to get there is to continue
to do things like this by man ap I'm
like reading your comment and liking it
I'm a big fan of getting dirt under your
fingernails and then cleaning it off and
going to a white cloth VIP super tide
out dinner there's just something about
that and that's why I like your comments
my man because I don't give a [ __ ] how
big I get I'm never [ __ ] going fancy
on you
[Music]